hello
i'm ted pine and i'm going to be talking
about pseudorandom generators for
unbounded with permutation variation
programs
and this is joint work with william hoza
and salil vadon
the pseudorandom object we will be
considering is the pseudorandom
generator
a function gen on zero onto the s to
zero into the n
is an epsilon prg for a class of
functions f
on zero one to the n to zero one if for
all little f and f the probability
that f returns 1 or accepts over truly
random input
is within epsilon of the probability
that f accepts given the output of the
prg
sometimes we'll also say that in this
case gen epsilon fools the class
f
the computational model we consider is
that of ordered branching programs
parameterized by width and length
a branch of program b has t has
n time steps where the transition
function at each time step
as just as defined as a function between
the state in w
and the next bit of input in zero one
this is a non-uniform model
motivated by the de-randomization of
space bound and computation
a space s algorithm using r random bits
can be represented as an ordered
prediction program
of width w equals 2 to the s where
intuitively each state refers to some
memory configuration
and each time step refers to reading
the corresponding random bit
for instance we have a width equals
three length equals three
branching program here and here we note
that there's an alternative perspective
where we can view a parachute program of
length n and with w
as an n plus one layer graph where each
layer has w vertices
and the transition functions correspond
to edges between layers
here we use red edges to represent the
transition upon reading 1
and gray to represent the transition
upon reading 0
and we note that we also specify a
initial start vertex
and a final accept vertex
just to make this more concrete here we
have the same order regression program
and we show how to evaluate it over some
input
so given the input 0 1 1 we
transition between states according to
the transition rules where
note here that the the transition rules
or the relevant graphs are allowed to be
different
between each layer and so we read the
input bits once and in order which is
why these are ordered read one
separation programs
and in this case we've reached the
accept vertex after reading the input
and so we say
that the branching program evaluates to
1 on the input 0 1 1.
an explicit pseudo-random generator for
branching programs of width polynomial
and n
and length n with seed length order log
n suffices to de-randomize space-bound
and computation
in that it implies bpl equals l via the
probabilistic method
a random function g on 0 1 to the order
log n
to zero to the n is a prg for polynomial
with branching programs with high
probability
the best known explicit prg however for
general branching programs
by nissan in 92 has seed length order
log n
log n over epsilon which is a quadratic
factor away from desired
here we have the fact that the
probabilistic method provides the best
possible seed length
and we desire to create explicit
constructions that are as good as a
random function
however given the lack of progress on
the general model
attention is turned to restricted
classes of branching programs
when we restrict to subclasses of
branching programs
we place conditions on the transition
functions for a regular branching
program
we require the transition function at
each layer to define a regular graph
since the transition function is already
too out regular this in practice
requires that each state has two
incoming edges
moreover for a permutation version
program we require that for every time
step
and for every input bit the transition
function
upon reading that input bit at that time
forms a permutation
on the stage w the width to
length one regular branching program
below is not a permutation branching
program
because as we can see the red edges do
not form a permutation on the states
in fact neither do the great
our focus is on permutation branching
programs of arbitrary width with a
single except vertex
this is an unusual model because
distinguishing functions can have
exponential description size
since the width can be up to 2 to the n
and arbitrary space usage
restricting to a single except vertex is
essential
since otherwise this model can compute
any function
day gives a prg for this model with seed
length order log n log n for epsilon
but that was not the main focus of his
paper which is in fact focused on
constant width permutation variation
programs
the best known prg for permutation for
entry programs of constant width
have seed length log n log 1 for epsilon
we now present our three main results
the first
is that the impoverished nissan
viktorson inw prg
epsilon fool's arbitrary with
permutation branching programs with seed
length order log n
log one for epsilon plus log n log log n
our second theorem is that a random
function g with seed length little of n
fails to be p or g for arbitrary with
permutation pressure programs with high
probability
this is in direct contrast to the
polynomial width case where a random
function already achieves the optimal
seed length
where here we give an explicit prg that
has seed length exponentially shorter
than that obtainable via the
probabilistic method
the final theorem is that any epsilon
prg for arbitrary with permutation
branching programs
has c length omega of log n log one over
epsilon
this is also interesting because we have
an explicit lower bound forcing
a multiplicative dependence on log one
over epsilon whereas for the polynomial
with case we have an atom we only have
additive lower bounds
of the form log n plus log one over
epsilon
in order to prove the first result we
first need to
define some notation given a permutation
for entry program
b of length n and with w the execution
graph of b
which we denote g has n plus one layers
each with w vertices corresponding to
the states
we can make this regular by adding the
identity matchings from layer n plus one
to layer one
as shown below we take some permutation
differential program
and add the identity between the final
and initial layer
moreover for permutation direction
programs this graph is consistently
labeled
the incoming edges at each vertex have
distinct labels
and this is important for correspondence
which we'll use later
we can then reason about powers of this
execution graph
given a permutation partial program b
with execution graph g
we can define the random walk matrix of
transition i
to be w sub i then the random block
matrix of g
has the form of a block matrix where the
block
in column i and rho i plus one
corresponds to the transition between
layer i
and layer i plus one then if we take the
elf power
of this random walk matrix or the lth
power of the corresponding graph the i
i plus l block corresponds to the random
walk matrix
for layers i i plus 1 dot dot i plus l
of the branching program and so
we have the fact that an edge v comma w
in g to the l corresponds to a walk in
zero one to the l
from v in layer i that reaches w
in layer i plus out essentially
edges in high powers of this correspond
to
walks over the input zero one to the l
that
go from a particular vertex in one state
to
a different vertex in the layer
corresponding to the correct length
our goal is to select a sparse set of
these walks that still approximates the
true power
recall that there is an edge between
state v
and layer i and state w and letter i
plus l in g of l
if there's a walk in zero onto the l
from v that reaches w
the graph b bracket gen induced by a prg
on zero onto the s to zero into the l is
the sub graph
where we have an edge from v to w if
there is a particular
seed for the prg such that the generator
output on that seed
gen of sigma in zero into the l when
used as
the sequence of bits from v reaches w
for instance if gen is the trivial prg
that represents the identity map on zero
into the l
then the graph induced by the prg is
simply the elf power of the execution
graph
our goal is to create prgs of length n
such that
the graph induced by the prg
approximates g to the n
in fact we can see from the block matrix
structure
on the previous slide that if we manage
to approximate the nth power of this
there will be a block corresponding to
w1
times w2 dot wn
and so we will manage to approximate the
products of the random walk matrices of
the transition functions
and thus approximate the acceptance
probability of the branching program
over truly random input
furthermore we have a useful
correspondence between powering these
graphs and concatenation of prgs letting
b
be a branching program and gen a prg
then the graph induced by gen squared
is equal to the graph induced by the
concatenation of gen with itself
intuitively on the left side squaring
this graph corresponds to
combining all possible walks over the
output of gen
with a second independent walk of the
output of gen but this is precisely what
the right side is
with this correspondence it may motivate
our definition of the inw generator
the inw generator is recursively defined
using a family of auxiliary graphs
h sub i where each vertex in h sub i
plus 1 corresponds to a seed
of the ithiow generator the base case
the inw sub-zero generator is the
trivial prg that outputs its one bit
input
rather than defining i and w sub i plus
one as the concatenation of two
independent imw supply generators
which would double the seed length we
sparsify by restricting to pairs of
seeds
x and y that are neighbors in h sub i
plus one
for h sub i plus one the complete graph
on the seeds
this is equivalent to using independent
seeds so we wish to use much sparser
graphs
that still provide a high quality
approximation
just as a as a notation note we write
lambda of h
for a regular graph h to denote its
second largest eigenvalue in absolute
value
and we're now prepared to state our main
result
the inw pseudorandom generator
constructed with auxiliary graphs h sub
i
with lambda of h sub i order epsilon
over log n
is an epsilon prg for permutation
variation programs of arbitrary width
we note here that the required spectral
gap of h sub i
only depends on epsilon and the
logarithm of the length
it has no dependence on the width of the
prg
and only a logarithmic dependence on the
length of the power that we wish to
estimate
the proof overview is we wish to show
that
the graph induced by i and w i plus 1
approximates
the graph induced by the concatenation
of inwi on any permutation parentheses
program b
using a connection to the d randomized
square and notions from ahmadinejad
kellner murtagh people saved and vedant
we now introduce some more details of
this proof
the randomized square of g with respect
to h uses h to correlate
two steps in g and thus select a
pseudorandom subset of wax and g
squared intuitively if we think of
taking
a step in g squared as taking two
independent steps
in g rather than including all possible
combinations
we only include the combinations that
are neighbors in h
this may seem similar to the iw
generator and in fact the construction
is essentially identical
we have this lemma from rosenmann and
vedan such that for any permutation
branching program b
where where the permutation condition is
important because otherwise these graphs
are not necessarily consistently labeled
we have that the graph induced by the i
i and w generator on b
d randomized squared with the i plus
first auxiliary graph
is equal to the graph induced by the i
plus first in w
generator on b and so now
we can work with the d randomize square
of consistently labeled graphs
our next goal is to show that repeatedly
de-randomize squaring a graph
l times approximates g to the 2 to the l
and so by this correspondence this will
show
that the log n inw generator the graph
induced by the long end i and w
generator approximates the nth power of
the graph
induced by the trivial inw sub 0
generator
but this is precisely the random walk
matrix of the prg
raised to the nth power
to do so a cam at all define a notion of
unit circle approximation between
matrices
for concreteness we can think of a and c
as the random walk matrices of regular
digraphs
we say that a is an epsilon unit circle
approximation of c
if the following inequality holds
we abuse notation and say that graphs
unit circle approximate each other when
the random walk matrices do
so we claim that if b is some
permutation branching program with
execution graph g
then if the graph induced by gen is an
epsilon unit circle approximation
of the nth power of g then gen epsilon
fools b
for the proof we take these test vectors
x and y
in the definition to be the indicator
vectors for the start and end
vertices of the prg where the start
vertex is in
layer 1 and the n vertex is in layer n
plus 1.
then the left hand side of the unit of
the unit circle approximation definition
we can see that these characteristic
vectors essentially cut out
the start comma and entry of this matrix
of these matrices and so their
difference
is precisely the statement of what
epsilon fooling
is on the right hand side we have
the epsilon over 2 multiplied by the
norm of both of these vectors
which are both one minus this
complex form which requires
that unit circle approximation preserve
exactly preserve all eigen spaces with
complex magnitude one
but in this case we use the trivial
inequality where we drop this negative
term
and simply get on the right hand side
epsilon
a cam at all use the d randomized square
and preconditioned richardson iteration
to give nearly logarithmic space
algorithms for high precision estimates
of random walk probabilities on earlier
in graphs
in order to do so they prove two
important theorems that we use
first the d randomized squaring yields a
unit circle approximation of the true
square
here we note that the quality of unit
circle approximation
depends only on the magnitude of the
second eigenvalue
of the auxiliary graph and does not
depend on the size
of the main graph being de-randomized
squared
this is important because the size of
the execution graph of a permutation
prediction program of arbitrary width
can be up to 2 to the n times n
and so a linear or even logarithmic
dependence on the size of the graph
being d randomized squared
would not give a non-trivial prg
second they show that unit circle
approximation is preserved under
arbitrary powers
and we show a quasi-triangle inequality
for unit circle approximation
from these we can show the main tool for
the upper bound
let g be some regular digraph and g2 to
the k tilde the graph obtained by taking
kd randomized squares
with some auxiliary graph family h sub i
with lambda of h sub i
is less than epsilon over eight k then
g of two to the k tilde is an epsilon
unit circle approximation of g of 2 to
the k
note that here we take loss linear in
the number of de-randomized squares
thus we require the spectral gap to be
bounded by epsilon over 8k
but this is lost logarithmic in the
ultimate power
since each d randomized square doubles
the length of walks under consideration
now we have the ingredients to prove the
main theorem
let b be any permutation branching
program of length n
equals 2 to the k and let its execution
graph be g
then let g 2 to the k tilde be the case
d randomized square of g
with respect to the expander family on
the previous slide
first we have that g 2 to the k tilde is
an epsilon unit circle approximation of
g
of 2 to the k second we have that
g of 2 to the k tilde is equal to the
graph induced by the k-th inw generator
on b
by the result of roseman and v dot
therefore
we have that the in w sub k generator
the graph induced by it
is an epsilon unit circle approximation
of g of 2 to the k
then by choosing test vectors as in
claim 4.6
we have that i and w sub k epsilon fools
b
since b was arbitrary and this
correspondence of resonant vadon does
not depend
on on the branch of program b we
conclude
we now move to our second result that of
the failure of a random function to be a
good prg
precisely a random function with seed
length little of n
fails to be a prg for arbitrary with
permutation battery programs with
probability one minus little of one
this means in contrast to the polynomial
with case our explicit construction is
vastly better
than that obtained via a random function
the key to this result is that
exponential with permutation branching
programs can compute doubly
exponentially
many functions here we give a specific
set of test functions
that we'll use to show that a random
function fails
the key idea is that unbounded with
permutation branching programs can check
permutations
let tau be a permutation on 0 1 to the s
then there's a length 2s with 2 to the s
permutation
branching program b sub tau such that b
sub tau accepts on x comma y
if and only if tau of x is equal to y
we show this by explicitly constructing
such a permutation for entry program
we identify the state of the branching
program with zero onto the s and let e1
through es be the standard basis vectors
we then give this transition function
which can be checked to define a
permutation branching program
because the transition function applied
to itself is the identity map on states
on input x comma y for the first s
layers
we xor x into the state of the branching
program so with layer i
we xor the ith bit of x into the state
at layer s plus i in the second half of
the branching program
we apply tau and then xor the ith bit of
y
onto the state
therefore b sub tau on x comma y
terminates at the state tau inverse of
tau of x x or y
then by choosing tau inverse of 0 to be
the except vertex
we see that the spreadsheet program
accepts if and only if tau of x
x or y is equal to 0 as desired
now let g be a random function zero into
the s
to zero one to the n with s little o of
n
then with probability one minus little
of one via simple unit bound
the n over two bit prefix l of sigma the
first n over two bits
of g's output on sigma and suffix
r of sigma the second n over two bits
are injective
in effect the second half of the prg's
output
is determined by the first half with
probability one minus little of one
but then there is a permutation pi on
zero one to the n over two
such that pi applied to l of sigma is
equal to r of sigma for
all seeds sigma then let b sub pi
be the permutation differentiate program
testing pi
as guaranteed to exist by the previous
level
we can see that b sub pi
applied to the output g of sigma is
equal to one for all seed sigma
in that the permutation for energy
program accepts on all outputs
of the random function however
b sub pi accepts a random n bit string
with probability exponentially small
in n so the gap between acceptance
probabilities over prg output
and truly random output is almost as
large as possible
and so g fails to be a prg
it's worth remarking here that the
reason the inw generator manages to pass
such tests
is that it injects new randomness at
every half
in effect if the output of a function is
highly
the output of the second half of a
function is highly predictable given the
first half
we show that there is a permutation
branching program
that manages to accept over this
function with a high probability
wherever truly random output it would be
vanishingly small
we can use a similar idea to show an
unconditional lower bound
of omega of log n log one over epsilon
for any epsilon
prg for arbitrary with permutation
branching programs
the proof idea is that if one half of
the prg output is somewhat predictable
given the other
then there's a permutation of
testosterone program that accepts prg
outputs with noticeable probability
the key lemma is for jointly distributed
random variables
x and y each over some universe n
there's a permutation tau
on n that satisfies the probability that
tau applied to x is equal to y
is lower bounded by two to the negative
conditional entropy of x given y
plus conditional entropy of y given x
the proof idea comes from the fractional
koning evergrevare theorem
and essentially what we wish to do is we
wish to find a heavy weight matching
on the distribution of the random
variables x and y
we now give a sketch of how we move from
this lemma to the lower bound
let gen zero into the s to zero to the n
be an epsilon p or g
for the model and x and y the random
variables of the first and second half
of the output
the first n over two bits of n and the
final n over two bits the five
the first n over two bits of gen and the
final n over two bits and gem
must both epsilon full permutation
parentry programs of length n over two
since permutation differential programs
can ignore sections of their input
by lemma 6.4 we have an omega of log one
over epsilon lower bound
on the sum of the conditional entropies
of x given y and y given x
then we can decompose the joint entropy
two different ways
uh using this basic um using the chain
rule
and then we have an inductive argument
which completes the proof where we show
a lower bound on
h of x and h of y and a lower bound on
the conditional entropies via the length
so in conclusion we've explored three
aspects of pseudorandomness for
permutation partnership programs of
arbitrary width with a single except
vertex
first there is an explicit prg
for the model with seed length nearly
linear in log n
second a random function with seed
length little of n
fails to be a prg for the model with
high probability
showing that there is an exponential gap
between explicit constructions and
random constructions
but in this case the explicit
constructions win
finally any epsilon prg for arbitrary
with permutation versus programs
has seemed like the omega of log n times
log one over epsilon
in contrast to the polynomial width case
we conclude with some open questions the
first
is removing the log n log log n term in
the generator seed length
this would imply asymptotically optimal
prgs for arbitrary with permutation
prediction programs
and would also constitute the best-known
prg for
permutation partition programs of
constant width via a simple union bound
over the except states
the second is the existence or
non-existence of prgs for regular
branching programs of unbounded width
where no non-trivial prg is known and
the third
is connecting back some of the ideas to
space-bound to de-randomization
thank you
you